wir könnten die drei fragezeichen an
drei dinge
anlegen nehme ich an den mieten decke
das vorkaufsrecht und die enteignungs
debatte in berlin drei mechanismen die
mich in berlin massiv umtreiben und
gerade gestern hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht entschieden
dass das vorkaufsrecht nicht so
anzuwenden ist wie es derzeit angewendet
wird und bodenpolitik damit zu
aktivieren der die
mieten deckel in berlin vom
bundesverfassungsgericht kassiert beim
verfassungsgerichtshof anhängig und
jetzt zukünftig die enteignungs debatte
ich glaube dass wir in berlin als
mieterinnen und mieter nicht die
richtigen instrumente der politik gerade
erleben um das mieten chaos in den griff
zu kriegen und was mich vielmehr dabei
ärgert ist dass ein berliner
mandatsträger schrieb in einem tweet in
der reaktion auf dieses urteil darf
zitieren das e-mobil in lobby imperium
schlägt zurück der
stadtentwicklungssenatorin berlin zeigte
sich fassungslos
zur erinnerung bei mieten deckel urteil
des bundesverfassungsgerichts so fragte
gesine lötzsch die ehemalige linkspartei
vorsitzende auf twitter wer von den
obersten verfassungsrichter eigentlich
zur miete wohne ich sage die politische
linke hat ein fundamentales problem mit
den urteilen unseres demokratisch unser
demokratisch legitimierten gerichte der
zweck heiligt offenbar nicht alle mittel
und deshalb bleibt die frage wann
akzeptiert die politische linke endlich
die urteile unseres rechtsstaats und
trägt dazu bei mit den richtigen
instrumenten eine mietsenkung offensive
in den städten die eine angespannte
wohnungssituation haben voranzutreiben
ich muss dazu sagen die richtige die vor
allem richtige initiative die es da
bräuchte ist doch einfach neubau wir
haben knappheit dann muss man neue
wohnungen bauen dass das ist ein prinzip
dass jedes kind versteht ich weiß nicht
warum der rot rote senat das nicht
verstehen so dass diese instrumente die
daran gesetzt werden nicht nur nicht
rechtsstaatlich legitim sind ist das
eine das andere was dazukommt ist was
die folgen ja auch sind nämlich
investoren vergrault wohnraum knapp wie
nie die preise für eigentumswohnungen
schließen nach oben das ist die folge
einer linken politik das ist also
entsetzlich was dieser stadt da auch
angetan wurde und ich verstehe auch im
übrigen nicht um das jahr 1900 berlin ja
zum beispiel massiv gewachsen da hat man
ganz neue viertel aus boden gestampft
inklusive schulen inklusive parks
inklusive u-bahn und das zu einer zeit
das ist 120 jahre her jetzt ungefähr
warum kriegt der staat es heute nicht
hin für massiv neuen wohnort sorgt ich
verstehe es nicht hamburg macht es
anders hamburgs macht es besser die
haben ihre mieten damit mindestens
einmal stabilisiert die sind in
vergangenen ganz oder teilweise leicht
sehr leicht gesunken berlin wird so wenn
es so weitergeht dass niemals
hinbekommen und die menschen wären aber
diesen senat ja offensichtlich immer
wieder jetzt kommen noch mal fünf jahre
dieser unsinn ja und berlin wird zum
labor für die bundesrepublik und das
thema vorkaufsrecht ist nicht nur eins
was berlin betrifft sondern es auch eine
etwas andere bundesländer betrifft
hamburg ist angesprochen aber ich frage
mich wie oft müssen linke eigentlich
noch vor unseren gerichten auf die nase
fallen um endlich die richtigen
instrumente in unserer stadt und unserem
land anzuwenden und welches verhältnis
hat diese partei eigentlich zum
rechtsstaat wenn ich mir die historie
anschaue und jetzt diese sache erst
mieten decke jetzt vorkaufsrecht und
nunmehr die enteignungs debatte die wir
in unserem land führen wie oft muss man
noch auf die nase fallen um endlich uns
mieterinnen und mietern die richtigen
politischen angebot zu machen ja wenn
das so ist wie sie sagen dann hätten wir
in münchen wo ich wohl eine
paradiesische zustände der kümmerer aus
solidarität auch die spd aber ich glaube
da kann man nicht allein an der spd das
abladen tatsächlich sind die preise dann
noch höher als hier
die frage ist ja einfach wie was sind
die richtigen instrumente
zusammen bauen bauen bauen bauen es muss
möglich sein völlig klar hamburg hat es
vorgemacht wurde es unter olaf scholz
das auf die wege gebracht
erstaunlicherweise aber was ist das
rezept nicht der markt alleine regelt
zumindest nicht überall in deutschland
also muss man sich ja fragen was ist
notwendig um diese knappheit
absolut auf dass du das teile ich dass
es um die richtigen instrumente geht
damit der markt wieder in das
gleichgewicht kommt und es eine faire
miete für die mieterinnen und mieter an
unserem land gibt aber die instrumente
die scheinbar rechtsbrecher recht zu
sein wenn man sich anschaut dass der
mieten deckel vom
bundesverfassungsgericht kassiert worden
ist dass das vorkaufsrecht vom
bundesverwaltungsgericht kassiert worden
ist und dass an der enteignungs debatte
in großer verfassungs vorbehalt hängt
und damit keine einzige frage gelöst
wird und da meine ich ausschließlich die
linke also die linkspartei sie haben es
jetzt auf die sozialdemokratie
projiziert ich bleibe mal bei der linken
die gerade hier in dieser stadt ihrer
herzkammer hat und diese ideen diese
fantasien immer weiterentwickelt zu
lasten der mieterinnen und mieter klar
nur die mieterinnen und mieter die
wollen ja nicht dass die preise immer
weiter steigen die wollen nicht dass sie
keine möglichkeit haben eigenen wohnraum
vielleicht auch irgendwann mal zu
erwerben zu kaufen quote ist ja relativ
niedrig immer noch im vergleich im
europäischen vergleich also und und
politik versucht das nicht ganz nicht
kindlich gut sagen sie bin ich bei ihnen
aufzunehmen und dieses gefühl zu
politisieren deswegen gibt es diese
initiativen die auch offenbar dazu
führen dass diese parteien gewählt
werden trotzdem muss man ja sagen da
gibt es das bedürfnis der menschen was
ist der weg da raus
den hat er noch den königsweg hat noch
keiner gefunden zu haben wir haben doch
gerade selber zitiert mit sinkenden
offensive alle an einen tisch zu holen
dafür zu sorgen dass der einzelne der
das subjekt unterstützt wird und nicht
mehr das geld im beton gebunden wird
durch den staat sondern wir umsteuern
dass wir mieten triff einführen also
gibt so viele möglichkeiten der job
center bau und der kopf und der zeit
dauert ja eine baugenehmigung in unserem
land länger als der eigentliche bau
vorgang das ist doch die absurdität
gerade wenn wir einen bedarf an 200.000
neuen wohnungen hier in der stadt berlin
haben und 1,4 millionen neue wohnungen
in ganz deutschland brauchen herr
hofmann ließ ihr gefühl als bürger und
auch als unternehmer wie ist es können
die menschen sich noch die mieten auch
leisten was brauchen wir also das frage
ich mich schon wenn man sieht wie die
mieten gestiegen sind und an den
wohnungen ist ja nichts passiert also
ist die gleiche wohnung im gleichen
viertel und die kostet eben nicht mehr
fünf euro sondern 20 euro jetzt an der
wohnung ist nichts gemacht worden
einfach nur dadurch dass man den
mieterwechsel immer wieder die mieten
erhöht hat was ist die richtige antwort
da sind die politiker gefragt ich denke
ein thema ist für uns alle als
gesellschaft ist dass wir nicht eine
gentrifizierung in jedem stadtteil hamm
wollen weil dein leben die leute noch in
ghettos und wir vermischen uns nicht
mehr und ehrlich gesagt das macht mir
mehr sorgen als bürger das eben die
vermischung der gesellschaft verloren
geht und wir dann immer mehr im
polarisierenden wohn strukturen und zu
den themen und zu den dingen
beschäftigen und die anderen vergessen
oder umgekehrt
ich meine darum geht es ja es geht um
den instrumentenkoffer der politisch
angewendet wird und dafür sorgt dass wir
genau die durchmischung hinbekommt das
tue ich am besten indem ich eine
subjektförderung machen nämlich den
einzelnen unterstützen und nicht das
geld im beton binde indem ich ein
angebot schaffe und damit auch wieder
einen funktionierenden markt hersteller
wir haben doch das problem dass wir in
ganz vielen regionen angespannten
wohnungsmarkt haben weil über jahre das
bauen nicht hinreichend forciert worden
ist dass wir zu lange baugenehmigungen
und genehmigungsverfahren haben da muss
ich mir überlegen wenn ich in dieser
stadt als gastronomen
genehmigungsverfahren durchlaufen muss
um den tisch oder ein stuhl auf die
straße zu stellen dann könnte ich doch
relativ schnell den verwaltungsbeamten
dafür einsetzen dass eine baugenehmigung
erteilt aber sich bitte nicht nur um den
tisch für den gastronom kümmert in der
stadt das kann der einfach anzeigen und
machen sich an die geltenden regeln
halten dann können wir tempo machen also
an ideen mangelt uns nicht wir müssen
das entpolitisieren und
entideologisierung das ist entscheiden
glaube ich und da müssen wir dringend
hinkommen unserem land
ja also wir sehen ja auch eine rückkehr
zur zu politik beim bau es war ja so
dass der bau total entpolitisiert worden
ist in anderen in der anderen in sich
dass nämlich gesagt wurde auch das
regelt alles der markt es gab viele
viele wohnungseinheiten auch berlin die
unter dem rot zugeführten glaube ich von
klaus wowereit geführten senat verkauft
worden sind weil das auch so gang und
gäbe wer das entsprechende angesagt war
natürlich auch im zuge dieser dieser
etwas markt orientierten politik dass
man gesagt hat wir privatisieren das was
staatseigentum ist und jetzt ist man
dabei das wieder zurückzukaufen was
gesagt nicht warum preis um sieben
jahren gesagt also bei uns weil man sagt
dann ist man nie funktioniert nach oben
nachdem die mieten aber in diesen
entsprechend objekten auch um das
vierfache gestiegen sind auch die preise
für den zu erwerbenden eigentum genauso
also da da fragt man sich langsam auch
wo ist da die perspektive der politik
die da handeln war besser spät als nie
kann man sagen aber es reicht natürlich
nicht aus zum siebenfachen preis das zu
kaufen das schon mal mein eigenes war
man braucht hier wege nach vorn braucht
neubau und eine entrümpelung vielleicht
auch effizienteres bauen das gibt es ja
alles diese möglichkeiten aber auch
nicht an also erleiden die eignungs
debatte die in der hauptstadt
deutschlands geführt wird kostet den
steuerzahler
36 milliarden nämlich landes
haushaltsmitteln wenn es zu dieser
enteignung käme von diesen 36 milliarden
sollen 240 tausend wohnungen in den
bestand also in den kommunalen bestand
zurückgekauft werden enteignet werden
enteignet werden nicht gekauft kost
trotzdem 36 milliarden weil am ende 650
euro für den quadratmeter gezahlt werden
pauschal im übrigen über alle wohnungen
wenn sie das geld nehmen würden könnten
sie 217.000 neue wohnungen baut und
hätten auf einen schlag ein großes
problem gelöst sie könnten nur damit
keine politik mehr machen und ängste
schüren
ganz spannende ist ja hat die fdp da
vielleicht auch irgendwie den letzten
jahren beim wahlkampf war beim
stimmengewinnen mist gebaut weil
irgendwie scheint die berliner sehr
zufrieden zu sein mit ihrer regierung
wenn man sich anschaut wie die wahlen
ausgegangen sind die fdp ist nicht mit
drin die union auch nicht wir sind alle
im parlament vertreten und wissen was
ich glaube das was berlin betrifft ich
glaube dass in dieser stadt die
wählerinnen und wähler eigentlich auch
einen regierungsauftrag erteilt haben
zum regierungswechsel und eben nicht das
weiter so wollten und schauen wir uns
mal an die linke ist in dieser stadt
abgewählt wird trotz enteignungs debatte
haben sie verloren bei dieser ball trotz
in eignungs debatte haben sie ihr
direktmandat in marzahn hellersdorf für
den deutschen bundestag verloren trotz
direkt man trotz dieser meinungs-
debatte die bürgermeister in den
bezirken verloren also die linke ist nun
wirklich nicht gewinner sondern ist gms
die fdp gewinner es geht darum dass man
jetzt eine politik der mitte macht die
die dinge miteinander
ausgleicht und auslotet stadt vermieter
gegen mieter auszuspielen und diesen
konflikt weiterhin anhalten und das ist
die spannende frage wieso gibt es
eigentlich am ende eine regierende
bürgermeisterin die einen politikwechsel
versprochen hat ohne ihn zu machen
bestimmt das hat sich so zumindest
insinuiert dass es diesen politikwechsel
wechsel auch gibt mit der fdp zusammen
konnte sich nicht durchsetzen gegen
teile der linken innerhalb der spd und
vor allen dingen auch nicht gegen die
grünen wir haben ja schon mal darüber
diskutiert ist die abstände zwischen
grünen und fdp in berlin weitaus größer
sind als im bund also da ist eine eine
liebesheirat noch in weiter ferne aber
vielleicht gelingt es ihnen ja mal
irgendwann diese brücken zu bauen